Bây đây, bác bị tám năm, bác ngày 7 tháng 8 năm, một hình chính trăm tám bị tám trong cuộc chính đấu vào về chủ quyền tổ quốc tại các mại đáng gặp mà.
Cô lìm và lên nào, thuộc quân đạo trên xác của Việt Nam mặc dù lực lượng phương tiện bố khi của ta nước đó còn hạch chiếc,
sau những người liên bình này ở ý đã chính đấu dũ gạm quyết tự đến cùng.
Trong số đó, sống như từ cán bộ, chiếc sĩ hải quân viên dân Việt Nam đã en dụng khi sinh đề vào về chủ quyền viên đạo của tổ quốc.
Hình anh em ngủ ngề sĩ thiệu ý trên quan phương, phó chỉ gi vì trực đạo và mà trước lúc khi sinh đá hình hăng quân há cơ tổ quốc quan thình mình.
Lần biên đồng đội không được lùi lực, phải đề cho mẫu mình tổ thấm há cơ tổ quốc và trên thống biên quan của quân Trung đã tiếp lửa cho tổ chè hôm nay tiếp tục vào về chủ quyền viên đạo của tổ quốc.
Nếu người chủ tiếp thăm ra vào về chủ quyền viên đạo của tổ quốc này ý, người thì ở lại tiếp tục cũng ýng xe dựa quân đội,
con Trung hải quân sau này, người cho về đời thường xe dựa quân đất nước.
Một em trung mà chính tôi cảm nhận được mỗi khi các thủ chính mình từng là những người liên biển ngày ấy.
Ló là niềm pin dự thường hào về phần chất to gạc bộ đội của hồ người chiến sĩ hải quân không sợi xin,
ra khổ, có hiến hảo xương giữ từng sắp đất đất biển của tổ quốc.
Hằng xa, trường xa luôn là một phần máu thịt thêm nghiên không thể thách dựa của tổ quốc Việt Nam,
mối sạch xa luôn, tương thật các nhành kê, họn còn nơi đây, đều mang hình hải của vôn thường xong rối, tấm đận 3 mùi,
dừng mẫu của các thịt người còn đất dịch. Tổ quốc nơi đầu sống luôn có các anh,
quân dân cả nước luôn vốn về trường xa, trường xa khu năng trường xa khu năng này luôn mạnh về phần thủ,
tốt về lối sống, gạc về cạnh quan muốn trường, mẫu một về tình và khết quân dân.